[Musique]
diego aux tons chauds d'été à la saq
emprunteuse un français sur cinq est âgé
de plus de 65 ans 11,6 millions de
personnes au total dont plus de la
moitié a déjà dépassé 75 ans cela pose
la question de la prise en charge de la
dépendance et des pathologies liées à
l'âge en charge des politiques de
solidarité le conseil départemental est
en première ligne pour faire face au
défi du vieillissement de la population
le conseil départemental sa mission
première c'est la solidarité et la
solidarité vers les personnes âgées
parce qu on a vraiment besoin
d'accompagner aujourd'hui la vieillesse
on sait que les personnes vivent de plus
en plus longtemps
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on soit là pour
nos personnes âgées
c'est une action qui était encore
renforcée par la loi sur l'adaptation de
la société au vieillissement et il mène
une série d'actions et de financement
notamment à la fois sur le maintien à
domicile et sur les différents
établissements qui accueillent des
personnes âgées
c'est un fait grâce aux progrès de la
médecine et à l'amélioration des
conditions de vie nous vivons plus
longtemps en bonne santé
la perte d'autonomie intervient plus
progressivement que par le passé de ce
constat découle une évolution profonde
des politiques de prise en charge des
personnes âgées
aujourd'hui ce que privilégie le
département c'est de pouvoir maintenir
les personnes âgées le plus longtemps
possible à domicile de manière à ce
qu'on puisse être chez soi dans de
bonnes conditions
aussi longtemps que c'est possible donc
un maintien à domicile ça se fait par
des associations qu'on suit donc ça peut
être la zam l'apalib qui viennent pour
aider les gens à se prendre une douche à
s'habiller
les gestes quotidiens aller à la
toilette pouvoir sous préparer un repas
c'est ce qu'on appelle la pas l'aide
pour l'autonomie petits puissent rester
chez eux le plus longtemps possible
on vit mieux quand on est chez soi on
est son cadre habituel on est près de
ses proches on peut recevoir des visites
et puis aussi parce que dassault c'est
aussi quelque chose qui coûte moins cher
à la collectivité d'accompagner les gens
à domicile aujourd'hui on se préoccupe
de chaque euro dépensé et on est à la
fois mieux et ça coûte moins cher pour
les pour la collectivité de pouvoir être
à son domicile
nous sommes devant la maia de mulhouse
une des cinq du haut rhin
cette structure départementale financé
par l' agence régionale de santé et le
conseil départemental travail sur
l'autonomie des personnes âgées
dépendantes
ici ce sont dix personnes qui oeuvrent
pour assurer le suivi et le maintien à
domicile des cas les plus complexes
personnes isolées et fragilisées
situation familiale difficile perte de
discernement gestionnaire de casser des
professionnels qui vont avoir une
mission particulière d'accompagnement
pour des personnes âgées dépendantes
dans une situation particulièrement
complexe et pour lesquelles on estime
qu'il faut offrir un service plus
présents pour leur permettre d'être bien
au domicile pour leur permettre de
réaliser ce maintien à domicile souhaité
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
une buy ins et un ensemble d'outils qui
sont destinées à accompagner les
situations les plus préoccupantes de
personnes qui sont parfois en constitue
à sion de grand isolement
quand la famille n'est plus en mesure de
prendre le relais
la collectivité apporte
une aide et une prise en charge globale
alors le gestionnaire de cas déjà va
essayer de comprendre mais qui est cette
personne âgée quel a été son parcours de
vie
comment elle a fonctionné avant et
aujourd'hui quelles sont les difficultés
qu'elle rencontre qui l'empêchent d'être
bien à son domicile donc on va devoir
évaluer alors on a des évaluations très
très cadré si vous voulez pour mesurer
les les incapacités et donc les besoins
qui ne sont pas couverts donc là on est
dans des choses très technique mais
ensuite on va essayer de voir aussi
quand des plans dette sont déjà en place
pourquoi ça ne fonctionne pas et là les
factures humains sont essentiels parti
avec un individuel pour identifier des
problèmes travailler avec l'ensemble des
acteurs de la chaîne de soin pour les
résoudre c'est l'autre mission de la
maia ainsi l'équipe départementale et
ses partenaires ont travaillé à la mise
en place d'un numéro unique pour
améliorer le suivi des patients à
domicile
comment fait-on pour se parler quand on
intervient au domicile et qu'on ne se
croisent pas si on prend l'exemple de
l'hôpital il ya un dossier un dossier
commun on se croise dans les couloirs en
échange au domicile ce n'est pas
possible
hélas le gestionnaire de cas non
seulement pour mission d'aider les gens
d'aider ces personnes pour établir le
plan daide mais surtout de se servir de
ce qu'ils constatent pour pour faire
remonter sa au pilote et le pilote va
travailler klizan l'ensemble des acteurs
du territoire pour dire on a telles
difficultés
est-ce qu'elle a du sens pour vous
est-ce qu'on vous accepter qu'on y
travaille ensemble et à partir de là on
va des clashs déclencher des travaux
communs donc c'est vraiment à partir de
la vie réelle des gens on ait un lien
direct avec qu'est ce qu'on peut
améliorer comment peut retravailler le
système quand le maintien à domicile
n'est plus possible
une personne âgée rentrer en ehpad une
démarche qui n'est pas toujours évidente
pour les personnes âgées et leurs
familles afin
ajoutez des lourdeurs administratives
inutiles à ce moment déjà compliqué les
deux conseils départementaux alsaciens
viennent de lancer le site via
trajectoire vient trajectoire c'est un
dispositif qu'on a mis en place il ya un
peu plus d'un an pour que les personnes
puissent s'inscrire avec leur médecin
traitant via internet sur un portail où
elles ont accès à tous les ai pas de
disponible autour de chez elle en
proximité avec leur médecin traitant et
choisi celui qui correspond le mieux à
leurs attentes et ainsi candidate et
puis être à limite appelé quand il ya
une place disponible elles peuvent
réactualiser leur profil
si la situation tout d'un coup ça grave
on peut actionner via trajectoire de
façon plus forte pour qu'une place se
libère pour nous sommes allés pas de
beauregard dans le quartier de dornach à
mulhouse
cet établissement de proximité accueille
80 résidents au delà des idées reçues et
malgré un âge moyen de 86 ans l'ehpad
est un lieu très animé c'est un lieu de
vie
ce n'est pas un hôpital c'est un lieu où
l'on vit et on prend du plaisir à vivre
debout
on s'est engagé en fin 2016 dans une
démarche humanitude alors il s'agit bien
sûr d'une philosophie mais également
d'une mythologie méthodologie qui est
service du la prise en soin dans le
bien-être du résident en accord avec ses
désirs avec ses besoins en respectant sa
dignité bien entendu c'est une
philosophie est une méthodologie qui
respecte la liberté de choix de chacun
aujourd'hui c'est l'idée c'est
d'accompagner les gens de tels qu'ils
sont de ne pas les contraindre de
pouvoir
leur faire leur donner un service adapté
à leur situation mais de ne pas être
dans une situation trop contraignant par
rapport à alors leur situation leur état
c'est vraiment être à l'écouté de la
personne âgée ne pas la force est
vraiment l'accompagner dans son là aussi
dans le plus d'autonomie possible si
elle a encore envie de faire des choses
elle les fait elle-même on l'a contraint
pas si elle a pas envie ben elle fait
comme elle le souhaite
cette méthodologie et cette façon
d'approcher le résident est un peu
différente de celle que l'on imagine on
recherche surtout un contact de
proximité le regard le toucher
relationnel la confidence qui se fait au
creux de l'oreille plutôt que de
s'adresser très largement dans une
chambre c'est le respect du rythme de
vie de du résident c'est toujours de
proposer le soin de ne jamais l'imposé
parfois de le différer quand il n'est
pas possible immédiatement c'est le
respect du résident que l'on accueille
le vivre dans cet établissement qui est
un lieu de vie le vivre debout jusqu'au
bout de la vie